flüssiges wasser am südpol ist diese
sensationelle entdeckung aus dem jahr
2018 wir hatten darüber berichtet um ein
großer fehler damals hatten radar
signale nahegelegt dass gleich mehrere
tümpel und ein riesiger see unter der
marsoberfläche verborgen sind doch die
enttäuschung mit der hilfe von aktuellen
daten und experimenten wurde eine andere
mögliche erklärung gefunden aus der
traum von flüssigem wasser auf dem roten
planeten oder doch hinweise auf leben
auf dem mars es ist kompliziert so viel
kann ich verraten sich zum schein future
geht es dreimal pro woche spannende
science wie das abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen vielen dank an die
community denn in zahlreichen
kommentaren und nachrichten habt ihr
mich auf dieses thema aufmerksam gemacht
2018 war es ja soweit fachleute wollten
einen verborgenen sie im mass untergrund
aufgespürt haben eine wirklich
sensationelle entdeckung und die
nachricht ging damals um die welt denn
in der fachwelt gilt da wo wasser ist
ist leben zumindest gilt flüssiges
wasser als die grundlage allen irdischen
lebens und so suchen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sehr intensiv nach hinweisen auf
flüssiges wasser auf dem roten planeten
ein wirklich schwieriges unterfangen
denn der planet gilt als kalt und
trocken in gletschern und in den
eiskappen der messianischen kohle gibt
es wasser doch fast nur in form von eis
oder wasserdampf flüssiges wasser müsste
wegen der dünnen mars atmosphäre an der
oberfläche eigentlich innerhalb von
sekunden verdunsten doch klar ist auch
würden wir fündig werden und flüssiges
wasser auf dem roten planeten aufspüren
würde dies nicht nur die menschliche
besiedlung des mars erheblich
vereinfachen solchen fund wer auch die
grundlegende basis dafür dass auf dem
mars ehrt ähnliches leben entstanden
sein könnte und vielleicht sogar eben
noch existiert genau aus diesen beiden
gründen war die aufregung groß als ein
italienisches forschungsteam vor drei
jahren 2018 raser signale als beweise
für verborgene sehen am südpol des mars
gedeutet hat doch möglicherweise muss
diese spektakuläre und spannende
hypothese der unterirdischen seen auf
dem roten planeten korrigiert werden
denn verschiedene fachleute haben noch
einmal einen genauen blick auf die daten
und fakten geworfen und die enttäuschung
ist groß wenn es also keine verborgenen
tümpel und sehen am südpol des mars sind
was ist es dann was dort im untergrund
schlummert alle spannenden text zu
diesem thema gibt es hier bei pixum
science im chip bis vor einigen jahren
hatte man auf den mars not winzige
spuren von flüssigem wasser ausspülen
können und das trotz intensiver suche
beispielsweise hatten sich auf die nasa
lande modul phoenix wassertropfen
niedergeschlagen in der äußerst dünnen
luft des mars befindet sich also ein
geringer anteil an wasserdampf das war
es aber auch schon fast an hinweisen
dennoch hatten einige forschungsteam
schon seit 33 jahren spekuliert dass
unter den polkappen eis flüssiges wasser
existieren könnte vergleichbar mit den
unterirdischen seen auf der erde gelegen
in grönland und der antarktis
hundertprozentig sicher waren sich die
forschungsteams allerdings bislang nur
dass es mal vor milliarden jahren wasser
gegeben haben muss denn darauf weisen
ausgetrocknete sedimente und flussläufe
hin und so wurde in den letzten jahren
eifrig diskutiert gibt es auf dem mars
flüssiges wasser oder nicht hatte
vielleicht sogar mal ein ganzer ozean
dem mars vor langer zeit bedeckt die
rada daten vom mars express der
europäischen raumfahrtagentur esa waren
das land vor drei jahren 2018 die für
aufregung sorgt die raser sonder hatte
eine helle reflektierende schicht an der
basis des polaren eispanzers delektiert
so hatten die daten also dieselben
signaturen angezeigt wie wir es von seen
unter dem eis informa regionen der erde
kennen und zwar rund 1,5 kilometer unter
dem eis in der südpolregion des roten
planeten planum ostrale ein
forschungsteam aus bologna hatten diese
daten so gedeutet dass es sich um einen
verborgenen see im mass untergrund
handelt und klar ist auch in
unterirdischen seen auf der erde wie
beispielsweise dem blake willens in der
antarktis wimmelt es nur so von mikro an
der südpolregion des roten planeten ist
es jedenfalls deutlich kälter als in
unterirdischen seen der erde bei minus
68 grad celsius könnte die temperatur
des angeblichen maße ist legen so hieß
es in der studie des italienischen
forschungsteams dass das wasser flüssig
ist könnte an dem hohen salzgehalt
liegen denn natrium magnesium kalium
salz und könnten den gefrierpunkt es
deutlich herabsetzen die studie wurde
damals im renommierten fachmagazin
science veröffentlicht und hatte nicht
nur in der fachwelt für aufregung
gesorgt natürlich wurde gleich über die
mögliche existenz von außerirdischen
lebens reguliert wie könnte dieses bei
einer solch hohen salzkonzentrationen
überleben als ausschlusskriterium wurde
das aber nicht gewesen denn auch auf der
erde gibt es mikroorganismen die mit
einer hohen salzkonzentrationen
zurechtkommen das italienische
forschungsteam schrieb damals sogar dass
dieser unterirdische sieg sicherlich
kein einzelfall auf dem mars sei zwei
jahre später also im jahr 2020 kunden
die daten noch einmal genauer unter die
lupe genommen und die aufregung
steigerte sich ja ins unermessliche denn
die neue auswertung der daten legte nahe
dass sich unter der eiskappe
möglicherweise sogar ein sozialer see
befinden könnte wow eine versteckte
lebensphase also der große see aus
flüssigem salz wasser könnte sogar 20
mal 30 kilometer sei zudem von kleinen
tümpeln umgeben sein so die
interpretation der fachleute auch hier
wurde die hohe konzentration von
perchlorat salzes als erklärung dafür
herangezogen dass sich das wasser im see
und in den tümpeln in einem schlüssigen
zustand befindet das forschungsziel
dessen studie im fachmagazin nature
veröffentlicht worden war schrieb damals
dazu diese gewässer an der basis der
südkoreaner eiskappe sind damit areale
von thomas pro biologischen interesse
doch bereits damals hatten einige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zweifel angemeldet und diese scheinen
sich nun zu bestätigen der neue analysen
experimente und messdaten sprechen gegen
die existenz von flüssigem wasser
anmaßend so hat sich ein nasa
forschungsteam beispielsweise insgesamt
44.000 ratlos aus dem inneren der südpol
eiskappe genauer angeschaut und schon
wurde der erste widerspruch offenbart
denn auch in den schichten nadals
oberfläche zeigen sich die rhader
signaturen die italienischen fachleute
als hinweis auf vermeintlich kräftiges
wasser interpretiert hat klar ist aber
dass es dort weit oben in der mars
eiskappe viel zu kalt ist für wasser in
flüssigem zustand nicht einmal extrem
hohe salzkonzentration könnten das
gefrieren des wassers hier verhindern
laut der nasa wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler kommt hinzu dass auch
die räumliche anordnung gerade
signaturen gegen ein wasseranschluss im
eis spricht dazu heißt es von der nasa
wenn das wirklich wasser wäre wäre dies
für sie kalisch nahezu unmöglich auch
ein weiteres aktuelles experiment
spricht gegen die existenz von flüssigem
wasser am südpol eines forschungsteam
hatte untersucht ob die radios
möglicherweise von bestimmten
tonmineralien stammen könnten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
hatten die sogenannten schmeckt eaton im
verdacht gemeint sind damit schicht
silikate die unter anderem entstehen
wenn basaltgestein verbittert dazu sagt
der forscher einsatz mit schmeckte
kommen auf dem mars sehr häufig vor vor
allem auf der südhalbkugel sie bedecken
den halben planeten und tatsächlich im
experiment zeigte sich dass die rhader
signaturen auf zugefrorenen smack titel
passen demnach stammen die
vermeintlichen wasser signaturen also
möglicherweise von poe mineralien
genaugenommen von gefrorenes mexican
dazu schreibt die nasa nach einer
genaueren untersuchung der daten sowie
experimenten in einem feld der labor auf
der erde glauben einige forschende dass
die signale möglicherweise von ton- und
nicht vom wasser versorgt werden die
erklärung der smag titel ist nach
ansicht vieler wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler also plausibler als die
existenz eines sees am südpol
möglicherweise haben wir uns also zu
früh gefreut dazu sagt der us-forscher
sachs mit die theorie des flüssigen
wassers erfordert sechs bis acht mal
mehr wärme als der mars liefert meersalz
in dieser region vorkommen was sie schon
von vornherein wenig plausibel macht er
jetzt zeigt sich dass die tonminerale
die beobachtung erklären können ohne
dass wird dafür besondere umstände
brauchen klar ist aber auch dass die
existenz der schmeckte unter dem eis
nicht direkt bewiesen werden konnte
eindeutig belegt ist also nicht dass
diese sich dort befinden die existenz
eines sees a mask und ist somit also
noch nicht hundertprozentig
ausgeschlossen hundertprozentige
gewissheit kann also letztlich nur eine
bohr mission auf dem mars bringen war
der mann sich durch kilometer dicke
eisschichten bohren müsste dazu heißt es
aus der fachwelt in der planet
wissenschaft kommen wir manchmal nur
zentimeterweise der wahrheit näher die
ursprüngliche studie hat nicht bewiesen
dass es sich um flüssiges wasser handelt
und die neuen fachartikel beweisen aber
auch nicht dass es kein flüssiges wasser
ist auf dem weg zu einer
schlussendlichen erkenntnisse können wir
nun aber zumindest schon einmal die
möglichkeit dessen was es sein könnte
stark eingrenzen denn auch das ist
möglich beide studien liegen richtig und
die oberen fundstellen sind spektive und
die untere flüssiges wasser das ist
wissenschaft manchmal kommen bei
untersuchung mehr fragen als antworten
heraus also was ist wissenschaft
milderes heißen meine wichtigste
botschaft exklusiv hier bei pixum der
amerikanische star
wissenschaftsjournalist erklärt warum
wir die welt nur mit wissenschaftler
erklären können anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und verteilen zeigt euren
freunden verwandten bekannten usw damit
sie auch verstehen wie wissenschaft
funktioniert denn das ist wichtig um
viele viele themen besser zu verstehen
bis dann bleibt dran